but the thing is that the premise for
talking out of it was
well we think you're going to lose the
money that you invest i was like well um
that was my expectation anyway we should
take a moment to
appreciate these these little things big
things
the things that move your heart i think
that's probably the meaning of life
as close definitions as i can think
there's a friend of mine
who who says like starting companies
like staring into your bus
and eating glass
and there's some truth to that
need motivation watch the top 10 believe
nation top 10.
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because chances are you
are the most ambitious person in your
circle which you know you're capable of
more
and you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best
elon musk and my take on his top 10
rules of success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one trust
your ideas i had a lot of friends of
mine try to talk me out of
starting a rocket company because they
thought it was crazy and what friend of
mine made me watch a video
if rock is blowing up
[Laughter]
and you know there were just lots of
people thought it was a really crazy
idea and there was some people that had
tried to start rocket companies not
succeeded
and they tried to talk me out of it and
but the thing is that
the premise for talking out of it was
well we think you're going to lose the
money that you invest i was like well
um that was my expectation anyway so i
don't really mind if i lose
you know i mean that might but i mean
it's not
it's not like i was trying to figure out
the rancor best way to invest money
right
on that basis um you know chose space
right i felt like that's you know i
thought wow
you weren't looking at like money money
market bonds triple a bonds
rocket company
invest in shoemaking anything um and
whoa space is the
highest roi yeah that's that is not what
i there's no
it wasn't the premise um i just thought
that it was important that
humanity expand beyond earth and we
weren't doing that so maybe there was
something i could do to
kind of spur spur that on rule number
two appreciate little things
well i was just saying that you know you
want to take a moment to appreciate
things in life and
the sensations food's incredible
and like there's just so many good
things that you can experience
some of them cost nothing really you
know
have a walk in nature or just a nice
meal and
it's like wow that's pretty great you
know and uh
we should take a moment to appreciate
these these uh
little things the big things um the
things that move your heart
i think that's probably the meaning of
life as close
definitions as i can think rule number
three make
better products you want to have like a
good competitive forcing function so
that you have to make the product better
or or you'll lose like if you don't make
the product better and and and
improve the product for the end consumer
then
then that company should have relatively
less prosperity compared to company that
makes better products
now now the car industry you know is
actually pretty competitive
uh so that's good um
and uh and and so then the the good
thing about a competitive company
in industry is then if you make a
product that's better it's going to do
better in the marketplace
rule number four persevere how much of
your success do you attribute to having
really audacious goals
or versus just not being focused on
the short term you know money coming in
or
on investors unfortunately i i when one
does have to be
focused on the short term and money
coming in when creating a company
because otherwise the company will
die so the the
i think that a lot of times people think
like
creating companies gonna be fun i would
say it's not it's really not that fun i
mean there are periods of fun
and there are periods of where it's just
awful um and particularly if you're the
ceo of the company
you actually have a distillation of all
the worst problems in the company
um there's no point in spending your
time on things that are going right
so you only spend on things on your time
and things that are going wrong
and and there are things that are going
wrong that other people can't can't
take care of so you're like the worst
you have a filter for the crappiest
problem
in the company the most pernicious and
painful problem
um so i wouldn't say it's it's i think
you have to feel
quite compelled to do it um
and have a fairly high pain threshold
and there's a friend of mine
who who says like starting companies
like staring into your bus and
eating glass and there's some truth to
that
um the staring into the abyss part is
that you're going to be constantly
facing
the um extermination of the company
because most startups fail uh it's like
ninety percent
ugly ninety-nine percent of startups
fail
so uh so you that that's the staring
into the abyss part you're
constantly saying okay if if if i don't
get this right the company will die
um it should be quite straightforward
quite stressful
and and then um the eating glass part is
you've got you've got to do you've got
to do the problems you're going to
you're going to work on the problems
that the company needs you to work on
not the problems you want to work on
and so that that's you end up working on
problems that that you'd really wish you
weren't working on
and so that's the eating glass part um
and that goes on for a long time also if
you want to have more self-confidence
and self-belief i've designed a special
free training to help you get it where
every day for the next 254 days i will
send you
a link to an unlisted video to your
email
to day shift your confidence and
self-belief forward
the science says it can take up to 254
days
of consecutive action to make a habit
stick
and i want you to get the habit of
self-confidence and self-belief the link
to join absolutely for free
is in the description below there are
just times when
something is important enough you
believe in it enough that
you you do it in spite of fear if you
have a great product lots of people will
buy it
and then the company will be successful
that ended up being worse than if we had
designed a car from from the beginning
rule number five have long-term goals
running a public company
is does have its drawbacks um so you're
not in a hurry
no okay
i mean in the case of tesla and spacex
we we had to raise capital and and we
had kind of a complex
equity structure that needed to be
resolved by by going
public um and um
and so so i thought we kind of needed to
do that in those two cases
we don't have to do that in spacex i
think there's a good chance we will at
some point in the future but
but spacex's objectives are super long
term
and and the market is is not so
i'm a bit worried that if we did go
public certainly if we're in public too
soon
that it that market pressure would would
force
us to do uh short-term things and
abandon kind of long-term projects
like going to mars right greenwich very
long term rule number six
ask the right questions when i was in in
high school i thought i'd most likely
be doing physiques out of particle
accelerator so that's
what as um physics and computers
i mean i got distinctions in two areas
in physics and computer science and
those were
yeah so my two best subjects and i
and then i thought okay well that i want
to figure out what's the nature of the
universe and
um so you know go try to
working with people banging particles
together see what happens
um and um and then it
sort of things went along and the the
super conducting super collider got
cancelled
in the us and that actually was like
whoa you know
what if i i'm working at a collider it's
been all these years and then the
government just canceled it
wow and then that would was like hope
i'm not going to do that
so um so it's like
well we roll back a little um
like i tried to figure out when i was
killed i had like this existential
crisis
and i was about 12 years old or
something and and i was like
what does the world mean what's it all
about
are we living some meaningless existence
and and then um
i met i made the mistake of reading
nietzsche and chopra and
yes and i'm like wow
don't do that i'm not it's not it's not
a little older i think
now and actually lately these days i
still rear it so
like you know it's actually he's not
that bad he's he's got issues he's got
issues
no question about it but but you know
it's anyway
um so uh but then i read
the hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy
douglas adams uh which is like quite
really quite a good book in philosophy i
think
and i was like okay we don't really know
what the answer is
obviously uh so but the universe the
universe is the answer
and really what are the questions we
should be asking to better
understand the nature of the universe
and so then to the degree that we
expand the scope and scale of
consciousness
um then we'll better be able to answer
the ask the questions
um and understand the
why we're here or what it's all about
and so
sort of take the set of actions that are
most likely to result in us
understanding what questions to ask
about the nature of the universe
rule number seven get comfortable with
failures
i always thought we would fail so this
is uh oh it's all upside
down you know i thought maybe we had a
10 chance of reaching orbit
starting out so then uh
if people thought when we started spacex
they said oh you're gonna fail
uh so i agree i think we probably will
fail
yeah it's worth trying anyway yeah
yeah how's that for honesty huh yeah
this this i said i'd lose
like you know lose all the money from
paypal i was like well you're probably
right
you know and we're almost there we first
three launches of falcon didn't work
then the fourth one we scraped together
some parts and
then that one worked and if that one
hadn't worked it would have been that
would have been it for us
so um i really believe in the future of
space and
and i think it's important that we
become a space frank civilization
and and not be out there among the stars
and i think that's one of the things
that
you know makes people excited about the
future and
we want the things that are in science
fiction novels and
movies not to be science fiction forever
we want to be real one day
rule number eight understand the why if
you think you're like what is education
like you're basically downloading data
and algorithms into your brain
and it's it's actually amazingly
bad in conventional education because
like it shouldn't be like this huge
chore
um so you're making it way way better
but i mean i think i think i think a lot
of things that i would say you've
probably heard
hundred times um and an effect are if
not
doing like the more you can gamify the
uh the process of learning the better
like
for my kids i do not have to encourage
them to play video games yeah okay yeah
i have to like
pry them from their hands like like
crack yes yes
like drop that crack needle yeah yeah
you have that problem at your house too
yeah
the crack is addictive yeah
so it's you know it's it's it's to agree
that you can make
uh somehow learning like a game but that
then
it's better um and i think unfortunately
like a lot of education is very bored
billion
um that you've got uh you know someone's
standing
up there kind of lecturing at people and
they've done the same lecture 20 years
in a row
and they're not very excited about it
and that lack of enthusiasm
you know is conveyed to the students
that they're not very excited about it
they don't know why they're there like
why are we learning this stuff we don't
even know why
um in fact i think a lot of things
people learn probably there's no point
in learning them
um because they never use them in the
future
because who's gonna launch a rocket into
space i mean that's just like yeah
exactly that never happens
um well you have to say like people i
think don't stand back and say well why
are
we teaching people these things and we
should tell them probably why we're
teaching these things
because a lot of kids are just in school
kind of puzzled as to why they're there
um and i think if you can explain the
why of things
then that makes a huge difference to
people's motivation yeah then they
understand
they understand purpose yeah um
so i think that's pretty important rule
number nine take advantage of the
internet
and think about the various problems
that we're facing or what would most
likely change the future
um the when they were in college there
were five things that i thought would be
um i mean i thought these were actually
these these
i would not regard this as a profound
insight but rather an obvious one
uh the the internet would fundamentally
change humanity because it's
it's like a humanity would become more
of a super organism
because the internet is like the nervous
system
um now suddenly any part of the human
human organisms anywhere would have
access to all the information amazing
instantly
zero link hey well i can imagine if you
didn't have a nervous system
you wouldn't know what's going on your
fingers wouldn't know what's going on
your toes would know what's going on
you'd have to do it by diffusion um and
yeah and the way information used to
work was really by diffusion one human
would have to call another human
or or or write them yes like if it was a
letter
you would have to write like you'd have
to have that letter to another human
that would
be carried through a bunch of things
fine another person would give it to you
extremely slow diffusion um
and if you wanted access to books if you
were not did not have a library you're
not you don't have it that's it so
um now you have access to all the books
instantly
um and you you if you can be
in a remote like you know mountaintop
jungle location or something and have
access to
all of humanity's information if you've
got a link to the internet
this was a fundamental profound change
and rule number 10 the last on before a
very special bonus clip
is tell great stories let me just tell
the story
yeah let's see if the story that you
tell is actually how does that how that
compares to
the reality because the reality is
pretty messed up so
hopefully the reality is better so you
wreck the car you get out of the car
you're doubling over with laughter
the person with you said why are you
laughing that you just
wrecked this car and you said no you
don't know the funny part it wasn't
insured
well the punch line's correct
[Laughter]
um yeah so i was actually i was driving
up uh sand hill road
um with with peter thiel the co-founders
of paypal we're actually driving to see
mike moritz
um this is in in uh 2000 and
uh so we're driving up essentially i
didn't really know how to drive the
mclaren
and uh peter says so so what can this do
[Laughter]
and then like i'm probably number one on
the list of
famous last words i said watch this
um so i so i floored it i floored it and
did a lane change
um on on santa hill and so the mclaren
has no
uh attraction control or anything it's
just it's
massive power to to the wheels so 600
640 brake horsepower and
it only weighs a ton so it has massive
power weight it can break wheels free at
80 miles an hour
so broke the the rear end free and
started spinning
um and uh i i i sort of
uh let's see i think it was sort of i
was i was going straight and then
turned um and and i remember seeing
the the the cars coming towards me while
i was going backwards
and then we hit the hit an embankment um
sort of a 45 degree embankment on
sand hill which tossed the car into the
air like a discus
and it kept broke it kept rotating with
about three foot of air air
clearance according to witnesses um
and and then slammed down on on the
ground going the
original direction um and we blew the
suspension out
uh and uh now it didn't actually wreck
the car the core chassis and the engine
were okay
um but but all the glass and the wheels
and everything which
was shredded and um and there was
massive body damage in the front and
rear
um and um yeah
did you start laughing um i don't recall
laughing
um i i mean
i could have been laughing in shock but
i don't recall laughing um
and um and and then peter uh caught a
hitched a ride to
to mike i i waited while the the fire
truck and the ambulance arrived then
finally the
did peter thiel literally hitch a ride
to to like
to get over to to sequoia to yeah and
then i
once once the car was uh taken care of
then i i used to ride too um
and so and we we continued the meeting
that's
i'm picturing you and peter thiel like
that scene and tommy boy
we're like the deer and you're both like
ah like yeah really
wow yeah is there apparel that could be
alive really
i i should say so yeah is there a
parallel with how you build companies in
that story
i hope not let's see
what you can do yeah watch this
that could be awkward with a rocket
launch
[Laughter]
now i've got a very special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day
i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week when you get motivated
inspired you have a 35 chance of
following through but when you get
motivated
inspired and you create a plan of action
you have a over
90 chance of following through and when
you share with other people
it jumps to 95 chance your likelihood of
following through and so i want that to
be you
from this video we don't just watch
videos here believe nation we do
something we take action
so i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week leave it down in the comments below
because i want to celebrate you what
drives you
what what is it that when you wake up in
the morning do you see a problem
and you want to solve it
uh i i think the the thing that
drives me is that i want to be able to
think about the future
and uh you feel good about that
um so uh that uh
you know we're doing what we can to have
the future be
be as good as possible um
to be inspired by what is likely to
happen
um and to look forward to
the next day um so
that's that's what really what drives me
is is trying to figure out uh how do we
how to make sure that things are great
and and gonna be so and
um that's the underlying principle
behind tesla and spacex
is that um i think it's it's pretty
important that we accelerate the
transition to
uh sustainable generation and
consumption of energy
um it's it's inevitable but it's it
matters if we
if it happens sooner or later and then
spacex
is about helping make life
multi-planetary and doing what we can
to continue the the dream of apollo
and ultimately
make contribution to life becoming
multi-planetary
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel
anymore i have a dedicated channel just
for it go check it out the link is right
there
next to me continue to believe and i'll
see you there